en una decisión sin precedentes de la
justicia hoy Nicolás arcosín se ha
convertido en el primer exmandatario
francés en ser condenado a prisión la
corte de apelaciones en el caso
polvismud o de las escuchas lo ha
condenado a tres años de cárcel uno de
ellos con obligación de cumplimiento de
pena pero también a tres años sin
derechos cívicos es decir sin poder
presentarse un cargo público y sin
derecho a voto la misma pena ha ido para
sus dos coacusados en esta causa terrier
shock Quien fuera su abogado y también
el exfiscal de la corte de casación
gilberg así ver recordemos que en el año
estaba siendo investigado por el
supuesto financiamiento libio de su
campaña la presidencia y la policía
descubrió que además de los dos
teléfonos que tenían bajo escuchas del
expresidente tenía un tercer teléfono
bajo una identidad falsa con el que se
comunicaba con su abogado a través de
las escuchas a ese teléfono la policía
descubrió que Nicolás Estaba tratando de
obtener información en otra causa en que
era enjuiciado a través de un fiscal de
la corte de casación a cambio el ex
mandatario Le prometí ayudarlo para
obtener un cargo en Mónaco Nicolás
arcosí niega las acusaciones dice que si
hubiera habido corrupción o tráfico de
influencias que son los cargos de los
que se le acusa el fiscal ahora habría
obtenido el cargo que buscaba en Mónaco
y él habría salido bien parado de esa
causa judicial lo que no ocurrió la
abogada nicolássi ha anunciado que
apelará esta sentencia al tribunal
supremo la máxima autoridad judicial lo
que Francia no habrá un nuevo juicio
solamente el tribunal deberá decir si la
sentencia de hoy es válida en caso de
que se confirme la sentencia Nicolás
sarcos y tampoco irá a la cárcel
simplemente usará un brazalete
electrónico